(jazzy music)
- [Narrator] Welcome to Norway.
Norway, the western part of Scandinavia,
It was established in the year 872.
The beautiful country is home to vikings,
an influential black metal scene,
a large nationalized oil
company and these arctic foxes.
So cute.
So while Norway has a
long and storied history,
let's focus on 2009.
No cultural event would
compare to the gargantuan
collossal, mammoth, very
large in size phenomenon
of this train traveling
from Oslo to Bergen,
televised for seven hours straight.
This is slow TV.
(upbeat music)
Slow TV is...
- [Thomas] Slow TV is...
A way of telling stories
- [Narrator] that is...
- [Thomas] told in full length,
along an unbroken timeline.
- [Narrator] This guy works at
the Norwegian Broadcasting Company.
My name is Thomas Hellum.
I'm working as a sort of project manager,
currently working a lot with real slow,
slow, slow (slurred to
slow motion), slow TV.
- [Narrator] He helped create a type
of television series that shows...
- [Thomas] a subject
that is somehow rooted
in Norwegian culture or that
many people can relate to.
- [Narrator] So some
examples are marathon long
episodes of people...
- [Thomas] Salmon fishing, 18 hours.
It took three hours before
we got the first fish.
- [Narrator] 60 hours of a
choir performing 899 hymns
from the Book of Norway.
- [Thomas] We had the
national firewood night,
with a fireplace burning for eight hours.
- [Narrator] You get the idea,
but how did Thomas come upon the idea.
- [Thomas] Uh, this was
actually done by accident.
(horn crescendo)
- [Narrator] Well so in
2009, Thomas is at lunch
with some colleagues,
spitballing some ideas
and had discussions over...
- [Thomas] Topics that take
long time, and other stories
that you could sort of
tell as they evolves.
- [Narrator] After a lot of talk,
- [Thomas] One of us just
said that why don't we film
the whole train journey
from western part of Norway
to eastern part of Norway.
It takes seven hours,
and why don't we just film the whole thing
and put it up on TV.
- [Narrator] They went to their bosses.
- [Thomas] First they laughed
and didn't quite understand
what we suggested.
But after have laughed a little bit,
- [Narrator] They realized that
maybe this was a good idea.
So they got to work and planned it out.
And on November 27th, 2009, the experiment
was released on air.
To Thomas' surprise,
- [Thomas] 1.6 million Norwegian watched
part of that program.
- [Narrator] So much people.
- [Thomas] And after that, we
thought, hey, this is a way
we can tell other stories, as well.
- [Narrator] The next production was going
to be even bigger.
A five and a half day boat trip going
along the Norwegian coast,
televised in real time.
- [Thomas] And we transmitted
the world's longest
TV documentary unbroken,
no news, no commercials,
no nothing, except this journey
for five and a half days.
And 3.2 million Norwegian
follow that journey.
- [Narrator] More than
half of the population
of Norway tuned in at some
point in the broadcast.
But why? What made this show so popular?
- [Thomas] Part of it,
of course, it's that
it was something completely different.
The TV was no longer a TV
screen, but sort of a window
as they were actually doing the journey,
as they were on that ship or on that train.
- [Narrator] After eight
years, Thomas and crew
are still pushing the envelope.
- [Thomas] If somebody had
told me that eight years ago
that hey, you're going to
make a 12 hour TV program,
I would've said they
were completely crazy.